What are the most common foods that can contain mycotoxins? Well same similar question we touched on before
Most common foods foods that would contain mycotoxins would be peanuts
And again, it depends on the type of mycotoxin, but in general you think of peanuts, grains
Possibly coffee
Anything that is stored and dry
That it microscopically may not be completely dry. So, okay, let's say coffee means they're stored dry
They still have a moisture content
Nuts and grains, they're stored dry and I should say corn is probably the most common of the grains
Stored dry, but there's a hollow center that if you were to take a laser and cut the thing open and use put it on your microscope
There's very large
microscopically
Center that can contain moisture almost always contains moisture and there's an acceptable according to the FDA
moisture content in grains that
Allows them to be sellable or have to be destroyed if they're too high of a moisture content
It's pretty much guaranteed. It's gonna contain mold and it's gonna contain mycotoxins and it's the consumer's gonna eat
How honest do you think some of these plants are the general males is testing, you know, you know every square meter of their core
No, they get a they get you know 15 million bushels of corn and they test you know how many grains of corn and it
Oh, it passes good enough and we're we're not gonna dump this and waste all that money
So we're gonna use it anyhow. No one's gonna be the wiser and they make chips on it and cereals on them into things
So how what what is the?
You know
Acceptable moisture content to these things. I have no idea in what the percentage of them contain do contain mold and or mycotoxins
Again, the world will never know
You can purchase
At least I know with coffee you could purchase coffee that's quote unquote mold-free because they test it
You know, it's of course it's smaller batches that these companies are
You know selling it at a higher price guaranteed that it's mold-free because they're testing each batch in smaller quantity so that they can
Have confidence that it's quote unquote mold-free
So you can't buy that as I don't know of any company. That's doing that with grains or anything else. So
It's it's difficult so
But the most common foods would be grains, corn, peanuts
coffee, I don't mind can have it and different mycotoxins and
There's any food that can contain moisture can grow mold and can then produce mycotoxins